hey it's andrew steven and adam this
episode is filmed at the beginning of
the year before we begin social
distancing due to covet 19.
and while we're currently practicing
social distancing we want to share these
great restaurants with you
even though dining out is not the same
right now we're in houston texas
we're doing breakfast sandwiches so
classic breakfast sandwich what does
that look like it looks like breakfast
in a sandwich right eating for breakfast
i'm thinking like
muffin egg some cheese
have to have cheese maybe a ham or bacon
yes
but what if breakfast didn't have the
halves of the sandwich closed what if it
was on a donut what if there were no
eggs on it whatsoever
is that a breakfast sandwich we're gonna
be finding out today
unworth it
[Music]
today i'm worth it we're going to be
trying three different breakfast
sandwiches at three drastically
different price points to find out which
one
is the most worth it at its price oh i
just want to say off the top thank you
to toyota for making the season possible
okay andrew like i hinted at earlier
the breakfast sandwiches this trip are
going to
challenge your convention of what a
breakfast sandwich
is i always like the episodes where
andrew goes rogue
andrew goes rogue andrew goes food
theory mode where are we going first
we're going to see andrew and his mother
nah at
cali sandwich to try their bon me
because bon me
from what i understand is eaten at all
times of day in vietnam
as well as breakfast
[Music]
can you tell us a little bit about uh
cali sandwiches we stole in 1993
at that time we only sell sandwich only
it's about 700 birth a day
your previous restaurant sold 700
sandwiches a day
yeah wow so you used to only make
sandwiches what do you guys sell now
we have pho we have egg rolls spring
rolls
we even branch out to stir-fried food
because calorie sandwiches in houston is
one of
many vietnamese restaurants what is it
that makes your food you know a little
different a little special
we make first every day we make
everything here we get here three
o'clock
you know in every store you know cook
every day fresh the second day they're
not fresh no more
they say that's gonna be too much work i
say i don't want people you know eat one
time and they say bye bye
the meat someplace they buy already cut
but we don't wanna like that
yeah you guys are very well known around
town like everybody i've asked who says
where should you go for bun meat
everybody says kelly's sandwich really
thank you thank you
i didn't know that yeah so once they
grill the meat they cut off all the
chars
she doesn't want to put too much char
because it's not really good for you but
then why do you charge to get the
flavor smoke it if you put on the oven
it's not that good our video is about
breakfast sandwiches i actually learned
recently that in vietnam
people eat bon me first thing in the
morning like this morning i'm walking
i was so hungry and i wrapped the half
sand with the steamed pork
oh my might be so good yeah so that was
your breakfast today
yeah yeah i think that's the spirit of
breakfast sandwich though it's a it's a
sandwich you can eat
kind of on the go you guys offer a lot
of different versions of the bun me
which ones should we try today uh combo
and the real pork
how much is the bomb me mommy is uh 3.69
what oh yeah
[Laughter]
thank you thank you thank you so much
cheers
cheers stephen
we got their thai iced tea that they
make in-house good morning andrew
good morning good morning good morning
sandwich good morning sandwich
we got a grilled pork and we have a
combo so why don't we have
half of each start with the grilled pork
let's do it it is a lot lighter than i
thought it was going to be yeah
cheers it's the perfect sandwich
regardless of the time of day that was
really fresh you know the first thing i
want in the morning is to feel refreshed
to get up you wash your face brush your
teeth yeah it's like looking in the
mirror
and slapping your face yes that's what
having a jalapeno
okay okay i gotta wipe that down now
we're moving on to the combo
it's like wait what's in here again pate
pork roll steamed barbecue pork steamed
barbecue pork and ham
that's a labor of love right there
cheers
the jalapeno yeah this one's a little
spicy huh
you know what's interesting about
jalapeno in an otherwise not spicy thing
a jalapeno makes you salivate more after
your bite
therefore making you want even more
sandwich
it's elevating i want some pate rich
patek cool it off you eat that
but hey there's a bite of jalapeno still
in there circle of
sandwich life couldn't have said it
better myself
breakfast sandwich fat time
according to historian heather arndt
anderson the breakfast sandwich has its
origins in early 19th century london
when factory workers decided a quick
and convenient breakfast on their way to
work soft roll used for the sandwiches
was called a bath
it's both a sad and a happy thing why
sad
sad because it was like oh no we don't
have time to eat breakfast anymore so
let's just
package it in a way so we can get to
work faster
but a delicious thing was born yes okay
so our next breakfast sandwich we're
going to see
mark and drew at squabble where we're
going to be having
their donut breakfast sandwich of all
the sandwiches we're going to be having
in this episode
this one definitely contains the most
breakfasty
items you know all right let's go to
squabble i i do respect the name
great name squabble
could you just give us a description of
what kind of restaurant squabble is
a rustic european restaurant with
american influences
which gives like liberty to kind of play
with cuisines like french cuisine
italian cuisine so you guys are
co-coaching chefs partners do you have
different focuses here
i mean i'm very much focused on the
bread so i you know responsible for the
donuts
mark is more responsible for like the
savory part of the menu
the mustaches was that before you guys
met like once you decided to start a
restaurant together you were like this
is the look
the last time we did a photo shoot we
said next time let's deal with mustaches
so
bread and pastry is really intertwined
throughout this whole menu right yeah
definitely
we have a specific bread section but it
finds its way into like pretty much
half the menu and so with this breakfast
sandwich that we're having today can you
talk about how that ties in together
in a roundabout way the sandwich is like
a croak mandam
but a little bit more playful and why
use a donut
so we serve donuts for dessert as well
for dinner a big part of this restaurant
is making sure that we utilize
everything as much as possible i don't
like wasting anything and we were like
well
what would be kind of interesting to do
and use the donut more than one way
generally the the ones that we use for
brunch come from the service before
we more or less need like a still donut
to be able to build a sandwich on if we
try to do
like a fresh donut it would be too hard
to eat the sandwich is layered with
ham and cheese so we use country ham
with gruyere you have
a mornay sauce which has a little bit of
mustard grilled cheese raclette cheese
and there's a little bit of parmesan
milk in there from cheese rinds that we
use
it was like okay crunk with them put
like egg on top i was like that's gonna
look really messy so we decided to like
separate the two
we comfy egg yolks basically poaching
egg yolks
in olive oil use the egg whites in the
sandwich and then putting the egg yolk
on top because everyone wants to see
that so he just kind of made it to where
it's the star
and then take the top part of the donut
and dip it in the maple reduction
um and then it gets finished with a
little flake salt i gotta say man
that's a lot of work and technique that
goes into making this breakfast
and that's kind of the idea behind the
restaurant to keep everyone challenged
in the restaurant and engaged
is there a strategy for what to do with
the yolk you kind of have to commit when
you're going to eat the sandwich right
if i were eating it for myself i would
just kind of like pop it and just pick
it up
would you eat it that way i agree with
that that's exactly how i eat it
i will admit uh it is the most
appetizing looking
bloody mary i've ever seen it makes me
think i'm just having a smoothie okay
i'm doing this for my gut health yes
cheers
thank you i mean cheers what
that's tasty i think i like that more
because
it felt like i was eating it i want a
fork and a knife so check this out fork
and knife
built into the table
nice i would like a separate compartment
for people to put their phones in
stop texting people definitely going to
forget that
i'll start
[Music]
yeah it's like mashed inside look at the
other visual on this plate
it's wild for those of you at home who
cannot smell this
the smell is very confusing it's like
is it dessert or is it ham
yeah i'm so messy that if i
go fork a knife it'll be as clean as if
you go with your hands
oh wow it is sticky
[Music]
oh my god oh my god the maple syrup
flavor
is just there enough you know it has a
donut
and maple syrup and it's not that sweet
it's because the balance is right there
you know
like it has a cheese sauce but it's a
sauce that's
very peppery and mustardy so it works
with all this other sweet and rich stuff
this is a killer sandwich this is
actually very well thought out
and i did not make the realization that
it's like a croak madam
i feel like i'm dreaming right now i
feel like i'm sleeping
and my wild mind came out with this
never heard that term before but it
totally makes sense i know about the
wild vine
[Laughter]
this feels really good to eat after the
sandwich
oh my gosh you got to try one of these
potatoes they're
unreal
i definitely almost forgot my phone you
did forget your phone okay yeah
we were about to walk out the door and
somebody pointed out that my
phone was in fact still in the drawer
at the table this is actually going to
conclude our time
in houston and our last breakfast
sandwich is going to be
in dallas road trip before we uh head
off to
our next place time for a little
breakfast sandwich fact
breakfast sandwich fact it's actually
not gonna be a breakfast sandwich fact
come on
okay bear with me our last breakfast
sandwich
is served on an english muffin so this
is actually gonna be an english muffin
fact
so english muffin fact english muffins
in england
are known simply as muffins
no way yes way so what is a muffin to
them i'm glad you asked
what we know as muffins in america
sometimes in
england they're called american muffins
no
way or sometimes just muffin
wait what yeah it's confusing do they
call it the english channel
the english channel over there or is it
just the channel and is that channel
just
bbc well we're here in dallas texas
because we're going to talk to
dean fearing and we're going to
fearing's restaurant to eat what andrew
we're having the crab eggs benedict off
their brunch men i would argue that an
eggs benedict
is an open-faced breakfast sandwich and
in fact if you go to wikipedia that's
what it says
i didn't make that edit look it's a
theory we're gonna test it out that's
the new point of this show
is a food what we say it is let's go
[Music]
i'm dean fairing i am the chef owner of
fairings restaurant located
at the ritz carlton here in dallas texas
so farians restaurant
is unusual in the sense that we have
five
different dining rooms and i wanted this
factor
to have people be able to sit in a
different atmosphere
each time they come fearings is a
southwest
restaurant but with many worldly
features southwest cuisine is
ingredients
indigenous to our area identifying texas
as its own food source the main
component is
all the influence of food that came from
south of the border we changed the menu
almost
every three or four weeks now we don't
change the whole
menu as we have some signature items are
buffalo
that's been soaked in vermont maple
syrup for 48 hours
buffalo soaked in maple syrup yes wow
unbelievable
our crab cake benedict is definitely
influenced by the southwest
crab meat coming from the gulf the
hollandaise being poblano of
tastes from mexico that i absolutely
love
using homemade english muffin i have
this theory about the eggs benedict i'm
interested in getting your
opinion on it so the eggs benedict i
think really is kind of an
open-faced breakfast sandwich of course
you agree i would agree yeah it's
probably the first of its kind
and if you wanted to have a breakfast
sandwich and a little bit more of a
refined
setting you need it with a fork and a
knife you do right
who's going to be making the crab
benedict for us today mike madis
is our restaurant chef i love the curve
and the little corkiness that mike
brings to the menu for me
generally speaking great crab cake it's
got to be like maybe 95 percent crap
so we put like a pinch of bread crumbs
or croutons you know a benedict
the most important part is when you hit
it with that hollandaise it looks fresh
it's appetizing
you know you just can't beat that flavor
stephen we've made it to the final
breakfast sandwich does my theory hold
water sure i mean you already had
dean agree with you so it's your
feelings that matter to me stephen
okay gonna say that here you know what
why don't you reserve your judgment
once we're done eating okay all right to
start we've got dean's margarita
well it's good tequila sorry this is
delicious it's uh it's strong
and it lets you know it's wrong so we're
here here and
uh we have this quite beautiful
and i mean benedict's are usually pretty
beautiful but this is
this is a different level of beauty that
i'm seeing right now i don't think i've
ever had an english muffin
that wasn't the store-bought variety
that is perfect yolk for me it's just
jammy
okay cheers steven i'm gonna come over
to you
yeah that's great hollandaise that's
crazy
yeah i just feel like i bit into a crab
this hollandaise
is like if a hot sauce was dairy
what if honda is like what is the
derivation of that i can tell you
oh you know you've ever traveled to
europe uh yeah did you ever
spend any days in holland yes we did
that's hollandaise
sorry what was your question you know
you've made this theory very prominently
a part of this
episode of benedict is an open-faced
breakfast sandwich
you're eating with a fork and knife
that's right that is the one thing that
i think
kind of deters me from your theory okay
you might recall
our double cheeseburger episode at
petite tour
the chef said sorry i'm france we eat a
cheeseburger with a fork and knife it's
a little fufu
but that's how we do it right i really
gotta say though the
the star of this dish it's the crab
super good andrew steven
how's everything tasty very delicious
tell me about this margarita well
everything is pretty traditional
except we use a mexican liqueur
called damiana that has a little bit of
a licorice flavor
yeah and i heard that you went and
selected the barrels of tequila yes
out of 28 barrels i picked
two for the hint of vanilla it's
delicious margarita
one of the best i've ever had thank you
for coming by and joining us and
and seeing what our breakfast sandwich
is all about
thank you look what you've done
[Music]
steven you look repulsive i am i don't
care if it's a sandwich or not anymore
i just want this to stop well steven
breakfast is officially over before we
get to our worth it winners
what was your favorite thing from this
episode that was not a breakfast
sandwich
egg roll cali sandwich what makes it so
crispy
oh the white paper some people use in a
frozen one but i don't like you which i
put
frozen i like that one i also have never
eaten an egg roll that was
wrapped in a leaf of lettuce yeah that
changes the game
andrew what was your favorite thing not
a sandwich in this episode
i think i will have to choose the bison
at fearing's restaurant we talked about
it but we did not eat it
on camera it's delicious they serve it
with a taquito which
breakfast sandwich was the most worth it
to you at this given price point
all of the sandwiches we ate today were
worth it
i also want to clarify that there were
also definitely sandwiches
and definitely consumable for breakfast
when you have to say definitely
twice in a sentence that makes a reason
to pause
but yes i would agree you know that
donut sandwich
at squabble seemed like the kind of food
that you would
you know scroll past on instagram and be
like
there's no way that's actually a good
sandwich but the way they have all those
components dialed in there at squabble
is delicious but for me my worth at
winner
has to be that bond me at cali sandwich
it's
a beautiful idea to just eat the thing
you want the most
first thing in the morning okay steven
which breakfast sandwich was most worth
it to you
at its given price if we were doing crab
cakes my answer would be
fearing restaurant if we were doing
donut my answer would be
squabble but we are doing breakfast
sandwiches
my dude and that's why my answer goes to
cali sandwich it's the name the value on
that which we don't talk about enough on
this show
is absurd ready one final question adam
who is your most worth it breakfast soon
adam
we had a triple worth it winner it's
been a while it's so nice to do a whole
video in texas
oh favorite thing that we uh uh sorry
had off camera that had nothing to do
with anything
we had dinner with my parents it was fun
yeah lovely people shout out to my mom
hi mom hi dad
last time i said hi mom and my dad got
mad so i say hi mom and dad
hi mom and dad love you guys
bye